i am curious i mean what is the best
part about getting to make a sitcom work
with people you actually really like get
to laugh and have fun together
especially when life outside is a crazy
and scary housekeep
what what is it like to go home with a
smile on your face
it's freaking amazing christina i'm i'm
in new york right now and it's it's it's
you know like to to to live in a world
where i can be walking around the new
york streets without an n95 mask on
where the biggest stress of my life is
what my tinder profile pic looks like is
a wonderful world to live in um
it's a wonderful way to experience new
york that i frankly missed dearly and
hope will come back soon but i think you
said it all in your question being able
to spend time with people that we that i
genuinely love
and being able to be put in scenarios
where
i have to like try not to laugh all day
long is is a great way to go to and come
home from work yeah
you know what one thing that
we all got to know each other like with
masks on you know and there's a genuine
like respect for for one another and an
interest in each other's lives because
we're all new to each other's lives um
and then the writers wrote this amazing
this amazing script for us to go and
like expose
this goofy
sometimes raw emotional side like it was
all in the scripts and we all
really watched each other work because
that's how the the format works of
sitcom that we were all really new to
was like oh we're kind of like all on
standby because that's going to happen
really quick and now we're like jumping
to this scene and that like
it just we were all there with each
other pretty much the whole season
watching everything that was happening
and and i think there was a giddy
feeling about being like on the
paramount lot like in hollywood like it
was romantic as hell i love lucy's shot
at our stages cheers shot at our stages
i think we walked in knowing we were all
really going to show up for our jobs we
had a really good script with a great
force of people behind us and we're like
we think this is going to work and like
just getting to show up there every day
and and have fun like it was
it was awesome i think we're all really
grateful to be sitting where we're
sitting
i mean they've said
everything that i i echo everything that
they say
um
that's true and the other thing is
what hillary said is that we were there
for each other i i think personally i
felt like i learned so much
from being on set to with this amazing
cast and crew and writers and and our
director pam fryman like that was also
so exciting that we were all new to this
that i was just like i felt like a
sponge just soaking in everyone else's
like essence and spirit and like energy
and thankfully it was just all positive
and good and
i mean you said it coming home with a
smile it was very i feel very grateful
to have gotten to do that
and i realized i was totally making an
assumption that you all like each other
but it seems that you all like each
other so
we do it it really does feel like the
the in order for a sitcom to work like
the most important thing is cast
chemistry because really all you're
watching as an audience member is
five six however many people in the cast
just having fun together
and i you you can't um i don't think you
can really
uh uh uh you can't you can't fake that
and um what was i think a huge relief
probably more for the producers and the
writers than anyone else is that when we
all met each other
immediately there was such a profound
respect and excitement about working
with each other that hasn't faded
quite a large amount of alcohol um also
helps um but yeah it is the the cast
chemistry i think was immediate and um
and exists off-screen as well as on and
it's just it's a blast to work with your
friends are you chris all told from the
beginning who the father is do none of
you know
how does that work i mean hillary do you
know because you're a producer like how
does this matter how does that aspect of
it work no they don't trust me like that
they know that i would be like
if someone would tell me something i
feel like
i think it happened i think it happened
during the sets the the season sometime
oh that storyline didn't end up
happening but remember when they told me
some big news and i was like i have big
news but we all have to be together and
like totally
just i feel like you're testing it
learning the information all of us is
like together in a collection be like
you guys aren't going to believe what's
going to go on in episode 10. like
there's such a we're
like bum rushing to like
tell each other what's going on it's
ridiculous yeah no we don't know the dad
and um
and we've kind of given up guessing
because we know that they're just having
fun with us at this point they're like a
cat batting around a like a toy feather
thing you know because
they're never going to tell us and i
don't even think they know
well tien's favorite line is to say it's
it's uh he's he has hair and a face and
a body
and some style we do know who he is
[Laughter]
and he's in the show or husbands yeah
seen his face
well obviously anything spoilery i'll
keep till it's not a spoiler but i i
love that we get the connection with the
apartment
so
what was it like to be on that set to
walk on that set see the set i mean that
must be
you must feel a sense of responsibility
when you get to do something like that
i'm gonna i'm gonna take the lead for
one second and then someone else please
jump in and save me but honestly what
i've been thinking about is really
that's the biggest tie-in with the show
yeah
it's like these are just the new people
living in this apartment that everybody
knows and loves and i love that that
takes the pressure off of our show
and and sends us off into being our own
show you know i'm not
the girl version of ted
you know
tom's not barney they're it it's not
like that and but you do realize like oh
this is just a new
this is the home of the the new people
that live in this apartment that we've
spent so much time in and that's a
really cool way to send us off and then
there's other things that happen and we
might have a visitor here and there
um but really it's it's its own show and
we're borrowing the
playing with the the past and the
present you know and those quick pops
but i think that really just gives the
show energy and is a quick way to tell a
story um and give information and and
and it just adds that energy to the show
but really like
someone else go yeah i think the
smartest thing yeah go go ahead tian
i i mean i love that we get that in the
first episode because i do think it
takes the pressure off of us because
it's setting the tone of like yeah the
spirit of the original
in that it's a group of friends that
you're gonna learn about that have these
amazing relationships and that have so
much heart like
at core that was what's so exciting
about how i met your mother we're a
completely different show with new
characters new people new friendships
that i hope everyone falls in love with
i mean i i as i watched our episodes i
was just rooting for everyone like i'm a
fan of every single one of the
characters that we get to know and love
and that's what's so exciting about how
i met your father
yeah all i'll say is i think the
smartest thing that the writers did was
not try and find who are barney's gonna
be who are ted mosby's gonna be i think
that
there's no way that anyone's gonna live
up to those characters except for the
actors themselves so why try and
duplicate that
and i think uh
the result of that is it feels like like
hillary and tim have both said
it's a continuation of this world of
some of these sets of some of these
circumstances maybe even some of these
characters we might meet that
harken back to the original but don't
feel like we're
like playing in the exact same script
structure every single time we really
get to go a lot of different directions
while
uh occasionally dipping our toe back in
the water of the world of the original
which i think is really fun for every
single audience member whether you're
coming to the show new or you're a
die-hard fan of the original
i think honestly sometimes we forget you
know that that there's like pressure to
live up to and it's not until like a
producer will come on set and be like oh
remember don't post any photos inside of
of you know jessie's apartment yeah and
we're like
oh yeah that's right because it's a big
deal you know or like carter will bring
like the swords from the apartment like
that he's had in his house for the past
eight years since their show ended and
now they're like in the fire about the
fireplace
like when my husband saw that he was
like those are the swords but like he
was like stoked on it and i'm like oh
okay yeah we you're gonna get a lot of
that but like for someone who didn't
watch the show you're not lost you know
yeah and i love that all of these
characters have plenty of their own
personal drama so
yeah it's just 30 year olds that are
just navigating
their 30s and and i think that
that's what made all of those shows so
wonderful and endearing and we hope to
do that too i think that's what we take
most from them is just
you know these normal experiences but
putting them on camera yeah well awesome
thank you guys so much for talking to me
i'm excited to see more of it thanks
christina take care christina